Speaker 1: I want to just stick in one little
story here about the grift train that continues
to happen with the former President Donald Trump.
We did 15 minutes at the top of the show about the
upcoming retirement of Supreme Court Justice
Stephen Breyer. Stephen Breyer, 83 years old,
is going to be retiring. And Joe Biden will get
his first of we don't know how many Supreme Court
picks from his presidency. And it is going to
be, I'm sure, just a pretty, pretty mainline
liberal who will keep the balance on the court
at six to three. And Donald Trump has immediately
started scam grifting off of this. Donald Trump
putting out a statement within minutes within
minutes of the news breaking that Stephen Breyer
will be retiring through his Save America PAC.
And it reads Breaking Supreme Court Justice
Breyer announces retirement. That's. True. OK,
that may be the only thing here that's true
Trump going on to say Joe Biden will fill the
vacant seat with a liberal activist. President
Trump has activated an emergency five x impact
to defend his America first legacy. Now, aside
from whether Biden will pick some extreme liberal,
which he won't. The idea that this does anything
to Trump's legacy, you're replacing a liberal
with liberal, Trump still got his three wacky
right wingers, including one who replaced Ruth
Bader Ginsburg. So the idea that this even does
any whatever you think about Trump's legacy,
this really does nothing to change it. And then
it says, please contribute any amount immediately
to claim your five x impact and
to save President Trump's legacy.
It doesn't actually even say who is multiplying
this or the idea here. It shows if you make a $45
contribution, another 225 five x another
225 will be matched. So by donating 45.
Your impact is $270. It's all probably a lie.
I mean, you know, it's conceivable that this
one time it's not a scam, but it's probably
a lie. And there's no indication here about
who is matching these funds or what is going on.
But immediately, Trump jumping on the scam wagon.
And my prediction is this this Saturday, Trump's
doing another rally. This one is in Conroe,
Texas. We're going to have people on the ground
there interviewing Trumpists. We'll try to talk
to them a little bit about the Supreme Court
and see what they have to say. But my guess is
Trump will use this Supreme Court situation
during his speech once again to try to justify the
election of Trumpists in November. I mean, it'll
be completely wacky. It'll make no sense. But my
guess is he will try to do that and we will we
will wait and see. But Trump immediately jumping
on the grift wagon, trying to fundraise off of the
retirement of Stephen of a Justice Stephen Breyer.